you
hi everyone it's Jerry the Legault trap
is a trap for white out of the Philidor
defense and it white offers the Queen
only to get the black king in return it
runs as follows
King pine opening night f3 knight c6
Bishop c4 d6 or in other words Italian
game turned Philidor defense Knight c3
and if black now runs with the
aggressive looking Bishop g4 placing the
knight in a pin this is a step in the
wrong direction due to white's reply h3
if Bishop takes Knight white is doing
better due to the bishop pair and
instead if Bishop h5 being persistent
about this pin black is found for the
Legault trap Knight takes e5 being the
tactical shop allowing for Bishop takes
Queen in exchange for matin with the
bishop takes pawn check king east 7 the
only move Knight d5 and that's game over
black of course does not have to take
the Queen there is an alternative but
before I get to that let me emphasize
the importance of this h3 move because
running with an immediate Knight takes
e5 allows black to not take the Queen
and instead just take the knight and be
up a piece and defend the bishop however
by playing h3 and kicking the bishop
back to h5 and only then taking on e5 if
black doesn't take the Queen and instead
grabs the night we get to see the
Queen's and great range in the game
shooting out to grab the bishop and
after Knight takes Bishop swinging over
to pivot on this b v square where she
gives a check and after let's say c6
Queen takes Knight White is up upon and
black has no compensation for it